In the last lecture we
introduced the notion
of virtual memory and added a
Memory Management Unit (MMU)
to translate the virtual
addresses generated by the CPU
to the physical addresses
sent to main memory.
This gave us the
ability to share
physical memory between
many running programs
while still giving each
program the illusion of having
its own large address space.
Both the virtual and
physical address spaces
are divided into a
sequence of pages,
each holding some fixed
number of locations.
For example if each
page holds 2^12 bytes,
a 32-bit address would have
2^32/2^12 = 2^20 pages.
In this example
the 32-bit address
can be thought of as
having two fields:
a 20-bit page number formed
from the high-order address
bits and a 12-bit
page offset formed
from the low-order address bits.
This arrangement ensures
that nearby data will
be located on the same page.
The MMU translates
virtual page numbers
into physical page
numbers using a page map.
Conceptually the
page map is an array
where each entry in the array
contains a physical page
number along with a couple
of bits indicating the page
status.
The translation
process is simple:
the virtual page number
is used as an index
into the array to fetch the
corresponding physical page
number.
The physical page
number is then combined
with the page offset to form
the complete physical address.
In the actual implementation the
page map is usually organized
into multiple levels, which
permits us to have resident
only the portion of the page
map we’re actively using.
And to avoid the costs
of accessing the page
map on each address
translation, we
use a cache (called the
translation look-aside buffer)
to remember the results of
recent vpn-to-ppn translations.
All allocated locations of
each virtual address space
can be found on
secondary storage.
Note that they may
not necessarily
be resident in main memory.
If the CPU attempts to access
a virtual address that’s not
resident in main memory,
a page fault is signaled
and the operating system will
arrange to move the desired
page from secondary
storage into main memory.
In practice, only the active
pages for each program
are resident in main
memory at any given time.
Here’s a diagram showing
the translation process.
First we check to see if the
required vpn-to-ppn mapping is
cached in the TLB.
If not, we have to access
the hierarchical page map
to see if the page is
resident and, if so,
lookup its physical page number.
If we discover that the
page is not resident,
a page fault exception
is signaled to the CPU
so that it can run a
handler to load the page
from secondary storage.
Note that access to a
particular mapping context
is controlled by two registers.
The context-number register
controls which mappings
are accessible in the TLB.
And the page-directory
register indicates
which physical page
holds the top tier
of the hierarchical page map.
We can switch to another context
by simply reloading these two
registers.
To effectively accommodate
multiple contexts we’ll need
to have sufficient TLB capacity
to simultaneously cache
the most frequent mappings
for all the processes.
And we’ll need some number
of physical pages to hold
the required page directories
and segments of the page
tables.
For example, for a
particular process,
three pages will suffice hold
the resident two-level page
map for 1024 pages at each end
of the virtual address space,
providing access to up to 8MB
of code, stack, and heap, more
than enough for many
simple programs.
The page map creates
the context needed
to translate virtual addresses
to physical addresses.
In a computer system that’s
working on multiple tasks
at the same time, we would like
to support multiple contexts
and to be able to quickly switch
from one context to another.
Multiple contexts would allow
us to share physical memory
between multiple programs.
Each program would have an
independent virtual address
space, e.g., two programs could
both access virtual address
0 as the address of
their first instruction
and would end up accessing
different physical locations
in main memory.
When switching between programs,
we’d perform a “context switch”
to move to the
appropriate MMU context.
The ability to share the
CPU between many programs
seems like a great idea!
Let’s figure out the details
of how that might work…